SPEAKER 1: In Android Nougat
7.1, that's API level 25,
there's an exciting new API.
And it's a total game changer.
It provides full platform
support for the most expressive
of conversational tools, the
JIF or even GIF keyboard.
Even better than that,
it's not just in API 25
because version 25 of
the support library
provides a backwards
compatible set of APIs allowing
apps and keyboards to support
it all the way back to API 13.
That's over 98% of
all active devices.
So there's two halves of the
API-- the outputting of emojis,
stickers, the G-word
and other rich content
for use by keyboard
devs, and then
exposing the input capabilities
and receiving the media for use
by app devs.
The flow goes like this.
When the user taps on
an EditText, the editor
sends a list of MIME types it
can accept to the keyboard.
The keyboard reads those
lists and displays content
of those types to the user.
When the user selects an
image, the keyboard calls
commit content and sends
that content to the editor.
We're going to look at the
flow for app developers first.
If you're the developer
of a messaging, social,
or any other app that can
benefit from enhanced keyboard
support, then by implementing
rich media this way,
you can accept it from
any compatible keyboard,
letting users choose
which they prefer.
To tell the keyboard which
content types you can accept,
you override the
onCreateInputConnection method
of EditText.
Then use EditorInfoCompat
.setContentMimeTypes
to populate the EditorInfo
object with the MIME types you
support.
It's the EditorInfo
that's passed
between the app
and the keyboard.
Then return your
InputConnection callback,
which you're going to use to
handle the incoming media when
the keyboard commits it.
Many messaging apps
have an EditText
at the bottom of the
screen for text entry
and then a pretty message
history or conversational
view above it.
We've got a sample called
Commit Content sample
app that displays EditText with
different allowed MIME types
and displays the incoming
media in a web view.
It's available in
the usual places,
in Android Studio samples
importer or GitHub repo.
Another thing it shows is
requesting and releasing
permissions for the rich
content being passed over.
For input method
editor developers,
gone are the days of copying
images to the clipboard.
Now apps can tell you what
content types they'll accept,
and you can start
flinging it across.
Simply override
the OnStarInputView
and you'll receive the
editorInfo object that
was populated by the app
and discover the accepted
MIME types.
Then you can retrieve your
current input connection
and commit the
content, ideally using
the compat version of the APIs.
It's worth mentioning that
Android 7.1 devices will
use the native implementation.
And that means you're going
to need to grant permissions
to the content URI.
We've got a sample IME
implementation as well,
and it's called the
Commit Content IME sample.
You'll also find it in the
Android Studio sample's
browser.
Now you can enable more
expressive and exciting
conversations across
your entire user base.
Excellent.
Applause.
[MUSIC PLAYING]